Oh
Oh
you
as you turn to the third part of the
communist manifesto you may wonder
what's going on here aren't socialists
all supposed to be on the same page with
each other why are marks and angles
engaging in all of this examination and
criticism of these various forms of
socialism shouldn't they all be aligned
with each other and as we're going to
see the Communists have some pretty
severe criticisms of why some of the
other socialist movements which which
are arising as a response to what's
going on in bourgeois society in the
late eighteenth and early nineteenth
century why these movements are not
going to deliver on the promises of
changing the condition of the
proletariat as the Communists say that
they'll be able to do so I put on this
this board sort of chart with all the
different breakdowns of the different
kinds of socialism that Marx is
criticizing reactionary socialism which
has three parts futile socialism
petty-bourgeois socialism and German or
true socialism true should be in quotes
they're conservative or bourgeois
socialism and finally critical utopian
socialism and communism and marks and
angles are targeting different aspects
of each of these movements so we're
going to go through these in part
because a lot of times when you're when
you're looking at a philosophy or a
philosophical perspective you can see
what they're proposing not only when
they're positively advancing something
of their own but when they're saying
something else isn't good enough
something else isn't going to work
there's a move there's a point of
comparison there and the Communists are
going to be putting themselves forward
is the only really true choice for
proletariat's who who actually want to
get something done who want to change
the fundamental conditions of inequality
and exploitation that he has been
diagnosed
so let's look at what he's calling
reactionary socialism first there is
futile socialism which he says you can
understand as being the last-ditch
efforts of the aristocracy but also the
clergy and these were two classes that
had been directly targeted by the French
Revolution that in other parts of Europe
we have been losing power I'm easy to
talk a little bit later about what's
going out of Germany at the time and
what do they do do they do they take the
side of the proletariat not really
they're more anti bourgeoisie than they
are pro proletariat and why because they
see the bourgeoisie as having taken
their power away as having supplanted
them in terms of where society is going
and who calls the shots and how things
are arranged so as Marx will will say in
order to arouse sympathy the aristocracy
was obliged to lose sight of its own
interest and formulate this in dyckman
against the proletariat in the interest
of the exploited working class alone and
he says you know a lot of this is just
sort of satire and Lampoon's it's not to
be taken all that seriously but if we do
take it seriously we find that this
can't possibly provide us with a
solution imperfect as he says in
pointing out that their motive
exploitation because the area you know
the aristocracy the nobles did exploit
the hell out of everybody that the
remote of exploitation was different to
that of the bourgeoisie the funeral is
forget that times have changed as he's
going to say they exploited under
circumstances and conditions that were
quite different and they are now
antiquated the the progress of modern
civilization and capitalism has as we've
seen faced all of these old distinctions
and the aristocracy are just not going
to be able to get those back mark says
something similar about the clergy as
well they says clerical socialism is the
should equivalent of it nothing is
easier than to give Christian asceticism
a socialist tinge Christian asceticism
means this doing without this you know
preaching abstinence austerity you know
for the good of your soul he says has
not Christianity claimed against private
property against marriage against the
state has it not preached in the place
of these charity and poverty celibacy
and mortification of the flesh monastic
life and Mother Church Christian
socialism is about the holy water with
which the priest consecrates the heart
brings of the aristocrats are you saying
look at you know Christian socialism
doing the same thing essentially as
aristocratic socialism saying things
were better back then you didn't have a
proletariat and was interesting he says
that the the real accusation that they
have to make is that under the
bourgeoisie the class is being developed
which is going to be revolutionary so he
says what they afraid them for the
bourgeoisie with is not that it creates
a proletariat that it creates poor
people working people that can't get out
of that is that it creates a
revolutionary proletariat so this is
just a reactionary mode and now it
doesn't you know propose a kind of
socialism but it's not one that's going
to be of any help what about petty
bourgeois socialism now when he's
talking about the petty bourgeois what
we're talking about are the people who
are able to engage in these capitalists
processes of production we have people
working for them perhaps in their shop
perhaps small business owners but
they're in a precarious situation in
modern capitalism why is that well think
about what happens when big corporations
and big box stores come to small towns
what ends up happening is many of the
local business owners end up having to
go out of business they drop their
prices as much as they can but they find
it difficult to compete with the big box
store which has economies of scale
they're buying goods in massive amounts
at great discounts and then
offering them to other people so the
petty bourgeois are severely threatened
by the ongoing progress of capitalist
society same thing goes for you know
anything that could be turned into a
chain so think about the you know the
haircutters who have to compete with
hair cutting chains that offer some sort
of you know reliable service up to
certain standards it's difficult for
them to compete unless they have some
some other things going for them so he
says that the the penny board Rosie
fluctuates between proletariat and
bourgeoisie if they manage to make it
big then they become the bourgeoisie
they end up running their own show they
become a corporation or something like
that in our own time where they get
bought out by a big corporation on the
investment money in the stock market but
if they don't make it then they fall
into the proletariat and now they have
to you know work like everybody else
it's interesting because a lot of small
business owners go through a period
where they are you know delivering
pizzas at night to try to you know
provide the seed money for what they're
doing working at best buy a friend of
mine who's who's got a good computer
company that's how he made us start
while he was just getting started and
you can become trapped in that now what
do they want to do it they just want to
restore the old conditions of production
they don't actually want to transform
society and what they want is something
that they can't have once the big box
store has come into town you can't turn
the clock back you can't get Main Street
back and that's what they're trying to
do he says that they want to they're
actually doing some good work in and
showing the disastrous effects of
machinery and division of labor the
concentration of land and capital in a
few hands overproduction crises the ruin
of the petty bore
the peasant the misery of the
proletariat anarchy in production
they're actually on track with that sort
of stuff but the remedy that they
propose isn't going to work because what
do they propose they want to either
restore the old means of production and
exchange like you know produce medieval
guilds again that's not going to work or
they want to impose limits on production
and exchange so that they can cramp the
modern means of production within the
framework of the old property relations
that have been since then superseded so
that also is not going to work you
notice we've got two different classes
here that are try that have come out on
the bad end of the stick in the
capitalist transformation in industrial
society they're trying to propose
something for the proletariat and say
hey you guys let this will be better if
we do this don't don't do what the
bourgeoisie are doing but what they're
proposing is just old stuff you know
something a little bit different when we
get it to German or a true socialism
marks and angles are saying these these
Germans and remember at the time that
he's writing we don't have one single
German state Germany is in the process
of consolidating there are some major
players like Prussia and Bavaria and you
know a few other states with in there
there's sort of a question of who is
going to unify a Germany but but there's
a lot of little tiny principalities
where the the aristocrats are running
the show and in the state like Prussia
it's the old nobility who are running
the show and in Bavaria it's a king so
in Germany you've got different
circumstances than you have in france in
france where the revolution happened you
have bourgeois society with industrial
manufacturing going on you have the the
proletariat who is becoming more and
more and more impoverished and in
germany is not quite in that situation
France also got rid of the nobility and
got rid of the King if you remember
right because the front
revolution so although they are you know
interregnum you might say with Napoleon
acting sort of like a king in an emperor
eventually they end up with
parliamentary politics and the
bourgeoisie bourgeoisie dominated German
or true socialism isn't going to work
because the Germans are taking ideas
that make sense in the context of the
French situation and they're bringing
them over to a more primitive state of
society where the real question is not
what are the bourgeoisie and the
proletariat is going to do with each
other but rather the ruling class who
happen to be the nobles or the the
monarch how are we going to get demo and
that's a question for the boredom of Z
so the Germans then start talking in
terms like I put here of humanity rather
than the proletariat and this takes
their focus away from the real interests
of the proletariat according to Marx and
Engels is this talking about humanity in
general is really just a cover for ideas
that don't mean anything or a cover for
bourgeois society the biggest problem
though is that German are true socialism
ends up playing into the hands of the
German nobility or the aristocracy
because the the bourgeoisie are not as
strong in Germany as they are in France
they're struggling to to take over to
assume power against the aristocracy the
German or true socialism provides a kind
of convenient pretext for the
aristocracy to actually crack down on
what the what the German bourgeoisie is
trying to do with the bourgeoisie wants
is a liberalisation of property
relations of politics all those sorts of
things they want something more like you
know post-revolutionary France and so
like it says true socialism serve the
government as a weapon for fighting the
German bourgeoisie it represented a
reactionary interest
to preserve this class is to preserve
the existing state of things in
Germany's talking about the aristocratic
class the industrial and political
supremacy of the bourgeois threatens it
with certain destruction from the
concentration of capital and from the
rise of a revolutionary proletariat so
it seems like like German or true
socialism can deal with that but it's
not actually offering anything to the
proletariat who are and indeed you know
starting to emerge in Germany as a
suffering class so that's all
reactionary socialism when we turn a
conservative or bourgeois socialism a
Marx brings up a few people like like 48
we probably don't know but very
interesting to read what they want to do
is to address the grievances that are
arising like this these working
conditions are terrible or we don't have
any money left and we're seeing these
rich people living a you know a great
life what's going on with that there's
grievances that the poor have the
working poor and why do they want to
address those grievances to keep the
whole system from going haywire falling
apart and being overthrown in in some
sort of revolution so the proposal as
Marx puts it is really to have a
bourgeoisie without a proletariat now
you might say you know that's kind of an
interesting idea but it probably doesn't
have any relevance today but if you
think about things in Marxist terms
today what is it that political parties
quite often want to offer as their plan
for prosperity for the nation we're
going to be able to poverty and the way
that we're going to deal with poverty is
all the poor people are going to have
jobs and they're all going to have jobs
in high tech because we're going to vest
a ton of money in education and then you
know they'll come out of the colleges
and there will be all these jobs open
form the knowledge economy that's the
same thing today as what Marx is
criticizing back in in the 1840s so he
talks about them as wanting to turn
everybody into a bourgeoisie or
bourgeois why because to be bourgeois to
be you know well off to be human well
we'll just raise the general level and
everybody can have some capital
everybody can have some wealth but you
can't have a bourgeoisie without a
proletariat not under modern industrial
processes of production and exchange
according to to the Communists so this
takes a couple forms you know there's
systems that they try not to try to
bring about that you know everybody's
going to have their little place and
everything will fit in together well
that's one way to try to do it another
way to try to do it is to do gradual
reforms in terms of governmental
administration the problem with that is
is that they don't actually change the
fundamental condition of class conflict
between the exploitative capitalist
bourgeois class which is driving most of
the benefits and the exploited
proletariat class all they do is they
make the system work a bit more
efficiently so perhaps the proletariat's
get a little bit out of it but there's
still massive inequalities and
imbalances in the system after these
reforms take place they don't actually
bring about a change in the material
conditions of existence so Lee says
we're doing socialism a TEENs adequate
expression when it only when it becomes
a mere figure of speech and he makes fun
of some of this for the benefit of the
working class free trade for the benefit
of the working class what does free
trade early work to the benefit of the
working class or does it work against
them mark says that it goes against them
protective duties for the benefit of the
working class that's the opposite of
free trade my way custom duties prison
reform for the benefit of the working
class he says this is the last word and
the only seriously met word of bourgeois
socialism it is summed up in the phrase
the bourgeois is a bourgeois for the
benefit of
working class and again you see that
because criticism is this form of
socialism doesn't really fix the
significant problems now we get to
something a little bit more interesting
and Mark starts out talking here about
some of the very early attempts to try
to you know bring about a utopia to
change conditions where the the laborers
are fighting against the new conditions
in which there any talks about the first
direct attempts of the proletariat to
attain their ends and these these were
involving Universal asceticism and
social leveling in its crudest form what
he has in mind there is the sort of
things going on with the levellers and
the diggers and all these different
millennia sects in England and in a few
in other places as well then he passes
on and you talk about what about in the
in the current day there are people who
see the proletariat as fundamentally
lacking any sort of initiative they're
not able to develop a political
articulation a party of movement of
their own that could really fix things
and they tend to look at the proletariat
as just the sufferance class as those
who are deserving of being helped out
because they're suffering not because
they're the ones who actually produce
all of the the goods but just because
things are unfair for them they're
they're suffering they don't have enough
to eat they're being treated unjustly
and what they do is they cast around for
some sort of new social theory some sort
of new explanation marks talks about it
marx and engels talks about in terms of
a new social science after new social
laws that are supposed to create
conditions that will change class
antagonism so he says in the formation
or he says the undeveloped state of the
class
will cause the socialists of this kind
to consider themselves far superior to
all class antagonisms and that's a
problem for from Marx anybody is also
problem for German socialism too by the
way anybody who thinks that they're
above ideology that they're above
identifying with a particular class is
probably fooling themselves as far as
Marx and Engels are concerned what they
end up doing that he real that they
really disagree with is they reject
political and revolutionary action they
try to produce changes in society solely
through not and violent and through
gradual action that would be you know
people would sort of agree to and move
towards that's what makes them utopian
and that only works for a short time
when you get like-minded people together
and you put them together in some place
like like these various utopian communes
that have been tried they usually can't
last very long and the problem is they
don't change anything in the outside
society they create a little microcosm
where there might be more equitable
sharing of wealth but they don't change
the fundamental condition of the world
the other thing that he criticizes them
for is producing reactionary sex so
you'll have some great theorist who
comes up with some ideas and and they're
actually being quite revolutionary in
the realm of ideas but not in the realm
of action and then their followers
crystallize and they say this is the way
it's got to be and it turns into
something that's reactionary rather than
being critical it does think that they
were able to identify some important
ideas he says they attack every
principle of existing society so they're
full of valuable materials for the
Enlightenment of the working class and
he talks about some of the practical
measures that they propose like
evolution of the distinction between
town and country that's an interesting
idea
abolition of the family the carrying on
of industries for the account of private
individuals abolishing the wage system
conversion the function of the state
into more superintendents of production
all of these are good ideas but the fact
that they reject political and
revolutionary action means that they're
never going to happen now this is a good
jumping off point to the very final
fourth section where Mark says put all
this stuff aside so the communist party
is a party for action for the working
class he says they fight for the
attainment of the immediate aims and the
momentary interest of the working class
but they also think ahead to the future
they take care of the future of the
movement how do they do this well
depending on what country we're talking
about they take strategic positions so
in a country where it's the bourgeoisie
and the proletariat and that's all
that's going on they're definitely on
the side of the proletariat's they may
line up with the bourgeoisie in order to
get rid of the aristocratic ruling class
so that then they can criticize the
bourgeoisie afterwards and this is what
he's talking about going on in Germany
he says they never ceased to instill
into the working class the clearest
possible recognition of the hostile
antagonism between bourgeoisie and
proletariat so that the German workers
may straight away use the social and
political conditions that the
bourgeoisie must introduce along with
their supremacy so he says they'll
they'll support every revolutionary
movement against the existing social and
political order of things they're
different than a lot of these other
things they're not trying to go back to
some past position they recognize that
industrial society is here to stay
they're not just trying to reform or fix
the system but rather to smash it and
rebuild it and they are willing to
engage in violent action in order to
accomplish that because they align
themselves with the proletariat so the
entire manifesto ends on a very
in a high notes as manifestos 10-2 he
says the proletarians have nothing to
lose but their chains they have a world
to win and then the call the imperative
is working men of all countries unite
why working men of all countries working
men and women of all countries because
communism speaking for the proletariat
in industrial society is articulating a
worldview that says that what
fundamentally matters are those who are
productive those who are in the class of
the producers and it only by all of them
putting aside their nationality their
old traditions all these sorts of things
that separate them will this situation
be changed and a new situation be
entered into